Ya.
Sebuah quantum circuit bakal jadi unit nilai
untuk bisnes kamu — qubit tu unit maklumat
tapi circuit tu unit pengkomputeran
jadi jom cuba faham apa itu quantum circuit
dan jom tengok anatominya
ini lah rupa sebuah quantum circuit
ia terdiri daripada beberapa bahagian — qubit-qubit
digambarkan dengan garis-garis mendatar ini, dalam kes ni kita gambarkan
sebuah circuit yang ada empat qubit yang kamu nampak
kat sini — sekarang gate-gate tu
cara kita kawal qubit-qubit tu
dan kamu baca gate-gate tu dari kiri ke kanan
dan gate untuk satu qubit boleh jadi gate
satu qubit atau gate berbilang qubit
kamu nampak kat situ gate terkawal
iaitu yang ada garisan antara dua qubit tu
dan kat situlah operasi pengelitan akan berlaku
dan akhir sekali ada pengukuran dan output klasik
dan yang penting sangat — kamu jalankan satu circuit berkali-kali
untuk dapat hasil dengan konsep shots
jadi kiraan shot tu adalah berapa kali
kamu kena ulang satu pengkomputeran untuk dapat hasilnya
hmm
macam mana rupanya
jom tengok macam mana circuit dua bit tu
itulah gambar tadi kan — memperkenalkan perubahan fasa
dan tadi saya tunjukkan operasi yang lakukan putaran tu
yang membenarkan operasi interferens tu berlaku
jadi jom buat perbandingan antara circuit klasik
dengan quantum circuit — dalam circuit klasik kamu
akan nampak yang kamu tak dapat tengok bulan biru kan
takde putaran — semua kat sini berwarna merah jambu
dan kamu dapat keadaan tunggal
yang dalam gate-gate ni kita nampak tingkap ketakutan
tapi perhatikan betapa berbezanya
bila kita betul-betul laksanakan quantum circuit
ini adalah circuit sebenar yang kita jalankan dalam komputer kuantum kita
yang kamu pun boleh cuba
circuit-circuit yang bakal kita cipta
dengan gabungan gate-gate
menjana amplitud kompleks penuh
gambar yang saya dah kongsi dengan kamu
tadi — kenapa tu penting
sebab kita sekarang boleh jana hubungan kompleks ni
antara qubit-qubit dari segi fasa-fasa
dan pengelitan, kemudian melalui tindakan pengukuran
kita mampu runtuhkan jumlah yang besar ini
daripada pengkomputeran yang berlaku di dalam kepada
suatu jawapan yang penting
dan begitulah akhirnya kita sampai kepada
jawapannya — jadi kita letak sebelah-menyebelah secara visual
kamu boleh rasa yang circuit klasik tak mampu
mengeksploitasi ruang pengkomputeran yang sangat luas
yang quantum circuit mampu buat — ia
gambaran terbaik yang bagi kamu intuisi ni
tentang kekayaan cara kita boleh akses ruang keadaan yang besar ini
Dan bahagian yang cantiknya ialah kita boleh
ada banyak kelas circuit untuk
buat fungsi yang berbeza-beza jadi
contohnya ini adalah circuit
yang direka untuk model risiko kewangan
ini adalah contoh circuit
yang digunakan untuk cari dan optimumkan masalah
dan ini adalah contoh circuit yang digunakan untuk
simulasi molekul — perkara penting
yang perlu diingat ialah kamu boleh reka circuit yang berbeza
untuk aplikasi yang berbeza
circuit-circuit yang kita reka tu kemudiannya diabadikan
dalam perisian dan disimpan sebagai perisian
dan dalam kes kita, kita simpan dalam Qiskit
iaitu kit pembangunan sumber terbuka kita untuk pengkomputeran kuantum
ini adalah salah satu kerangka perisian
yang paling banyak digunakan untuk pengkomputeran kuantum
dan kamu boleh bayangkan membina
perpustakaan circuit-circuit yang ditanam dalam
atur cara klasik yang kini menggabungkan yang terbaik daripada pengaturcaraan klasik
dan yang terbaik daripada kuasa kuantum